RICK BOROVOY: Hi,
I'm Rick Borovoy.
I'm the Lead Product Manager
for Google Play for Education.
JULIE FARAGO: And
I'm Julie Farago.
I'm the Engineering Manager
for Google Play for Education.
RICK BOROVOY: So I get you.
You want to change the world
with your mad software skills,
but you don't know
where to start.
So in five minutes
we're going to pitch you
on a "rock your paradigm"
educational Android app that we
are dying for someone to
build that could transform
a classroom into an amazing
place for collaboration
and exploration.
JULIE FARAGO: I'm really
excited about this,
but we're not just
going to tantalize you
with exciting ideas.
We're actually going to teach
you about the Google APIs
that you can use that
makes it easy to build
these apps and really any app
that you're excited about.
And we've actually already
created the Google Play
for Education store that
you could put your app there
and super easily get it into the
hands of teachers and students.
So the biggest thing
that needs to be done
is just building that app.
So let's learn how.
RICK BOROVOY: We
want you to build
an app that nails one of
the most awesome, most
popular, collaborative
tablet use cases in school.
It's called the Photo Hunt,
or sometimes the Photo Safari.
As in, I'm the teacher.
Hey, kids.
For our unit on
energy conservation
go grab your tablets and take
some pictures of examples
of how we're wasting
energy at school.
That's easy.
And it's really
empowering for kids
to go and find some examples
of waste with their camera.
Like a door left open when
the air conditioner's running.
Or school buses
belching carbon monoxide
while they're sitting
there waiting for the kids
to come out.
Or entire labs
where the computers
powered on but sitting unused.
JULIE FARAGO: Turn them off.
RICK BOROVOY: Now
there are existing apps
for this that support the basic
photo collection reasonably
well.
But as awesome as kids taking
pictures around the school is,
it's actually not the magic
moment of the Photo Hunt.
The real magic happens when
the kids gather back together
with the teacher and they look
over what they've collected
and they start talking
about it and start
pulling out ideas
and really getting
focused on what
they've collected.
It turns out that that
focus can be a challenge.
Teacher may want to point
out a couple of photos,
but the kids are wandering off.
In fact, a teacher
once told me that kids
have a superhuman ability
to be on the wrong page
at the wrong time.
So how about building something
straight into the Photo Hunt
app that lets a
teacher walk students
through a particular photo, so
that they can control the focus
and really make an
awesome conversation.
JULIE FARAGO: Totally.
So I love this idea.
I think I get it.
Let's walk through how
to actually build it.
So first of all, if you want
to use the tablet as a camera,
or for that matter an audio
sensor or a video recorder,
please actually check out the
Google Android media and camera
APIs.
These are going to give you
all the tools that you need
to capture and record multimedia
so that when you're building
for a tablet you can
actually take advantage
of the awesome mobility and
multimedia of that tablet.
We want apps that just shine
on tablets-- that you just
couldn't do otherwise--
because the tablet form
factor is so fabulous.
And we think that
you can build apps
that take advantage of that.
So, all right, let's say you
understand how to take photos.
What you're going to need
is a source of identity.
And when kids are gathering
and commenting on photos,
they actually need a
way to say who they are.
And I'm going to go a little
melodramatic here, but bear
with me.
Because the thing that
you want to be careful of
is that identity is the first
place where apps go to die.
I know, intense.
But so we went to a
classroom earlier this year
in New Hampshire.
And what we saw was 20
pages-- 20 plus or minus--
stapled together mapping
app name to kid name
to username to password.
And there is nothing
that will make
a teacher abandon your app
more quickly than wasting her,
or even more importantly,
her student's time.
And requiring unique
usernames and passwords
for all of these students?
It's just a waste of time.
So you can make this
easier with Google Login.
So with really
minimal effort, you
can get a trusted
registration system
that's familiar to users.
It's consistent across devices.
And it just lets you skip all
that time intensive username
and password entering.
And it makes registration
faster and more secure.
And the awesome
thing about this is
that all the students
in your classes
are actually going to
have Google Apps accounts.
They're going to have Google
Login available to them.
Because you need it in order to
use Google Play for Education.
So 100% of those
students are going
to be able to click
that sign in button
and use it for registration,
use it for log in, and just go.
So no login, no password.
Happy teachers.
Great.
RICK BOROVOY: Amazing.
JULIE FARAGO: Amazing.
So now the next question
is, how do we really
get to the heart of what Rick
was talking about earlier?
How do we get
students all talking
about the same thing, on the
same page, at the same time?
And for that we're actually
introducing a new Android
API that lets an app go
into lock to app mode.
This API actually
needs to be authorized
through device management.
So you want to be thoughtful
about how you use it and use it
in apps like testing apps,
or classroom management apps,
or, in this case, a task
focused app, where you really
want to keep all the
kids on the same image,
keep the discussion
focused, and keep kids
from getting distracted and
going off to another place.
So now what you
can do is you can
build this special
discussion mode into your app
so that when a teacher, for
example, swipes between photos,
the students'
tablets follow along.
So they can all look at this
one picture of the exhaust pipe
and all the gas
coming out of it.
And because you've used
this lock to app API,
all of the basic navigation
buttons and the notifications
are turned off so they can't
accidentally or intentionally
switch out of the
app and wander off.
So you can find out more about
this in the Android L Preview
release.
RICK BOROVOY: I love the
idea of a discussion mode.
So that feels like
that completely
nails the Photo Safari use case.
But I'm thinking if you
give kids this awesome power
to collect these photos
and discuss them and start
to think about the
world around them,
they're going to want
to start arranging them
in a way that represents
the world around them.
They're going to want to map.
Of course, we love
maps at Google.
But we also think it's
an amazing way for kids
to work together to build an
understanding of the world
around them and maybe
even to use a map
to advocate for
positive social change.
JULIE FARAGO: Totally.
RICK BOROVOY:
Remarkably, there isn't
a tool that makes this
really simple for kids
to do-- to decide what matters
to them and map it out.
For example, a tool that
would help our conservation
minded kids.
Maybe they want to make their
school more bike friendly
or find out how
bike friendly it is.
So they want to map
the surrounding first
for bike friendliness.
Maybe they want to
map out three things.
Where are bike racks?
Where are bike lanes?
Or where are bike hazards
that they should be aware of?
So imagine a tool that lets kids
decide those three markers, fan
out with their GPS devices,
start marking on the map where
those things are, take some
photos, and then just magically
have it gather all together so
they can study it themselves
and then share it
with other people.
JULIE FARAGO: I love this app.
I want to use this app.
It sounds fabulous.
And the big question is,
how do you do it easily?
And the Google Maps API
actually makes this really easy.
You can build this functionality
on top of Google Maps,
and you can get a bunch
of gnarly engineering work
for free.
So you can get a shared Cloud
synced set of map markers
that are contributed
to by a group of users.
You can get GPS integration,
fantastic and familiar
touch UX, maps that span the
entire earth, and, of course,
custom map markers.
In fact, actually,
one of our schools
earlier this year did
this amazing project
where kids went
around their town
and they took pictures
of street lights--
street lights that were working,
street lights that were out,
where they needed
more street lights.
And using that, they actually
made a shared proposal
to their local town
government about what
they should do about
their streetlights.
And it was fantastic.
But the challenge
was actually that it
required a ton of IT support.
And, of course, a ton
of teacher support.
You want the teacher
supportive, but you
don't want them to have to
work long weekends in order
to enable this
project to happen.
And so what we
really need here is
we want students
all over the country
to be able to do these
types of things, teachers
to be able to do
it, without having
to invest oodles of time.
And for that we need an app.
And we're hopeful
that you'll build one.
RICK BOROVOY: Boom.
Awesome.
All right.
So now we've got this app that
lets kids collaborate, explore,
document their
world, organize it.
But I don't think we're done.
I think that the
missing piece is
that these kids want to do
more than just collect photos.
They want to collect data.
Maybe it's not just the kids
that want to collect data.
Maybe it's the teachers
I have not met a teacher
that isn't really
passionate about
getting their kids to be
excited about collecting
and analyzing data.
It's an ultimate
21st century skill.
But there's a funny
truth about how it often
goes down in schools.
It often looks
something like kid
in the back measuring the
pH value of the puddle.
And I think that's just less
exciting than maybe teachers
and we all hope
it's going to be.
Kids somehow figured
out that this
isn't the way to a Nobel Prize.
And it's not the most
exciting use of data.
So what if we just took
a lot better advantage
of what we have to offer here?
You don't just have one kid
and one scientific instrument.
You've got a whole
classroom worth of tablets.
Isn't there some cool way we can
combine these tablets together
into some super
scientific instrument?
You've ever been to the
Very Large Array in Arizona?
JULIE FARAGO: I
have not, actually.
RICK BOROVOY: It's
totally awesome.
It's like the modern
day Stonehenge.
There are all these
radio telescopes
that all work together.
I'm not talking about making
radio telescopes work together.
But what if you can
take nine tablets
and put them together
in an array and then
use that single big array to
go measure sound in the school.
Maybe you take it into a
classroom and you look and see
how the sound travels in there.
Or maybe you take it into an
auditorium and you look and see
how the sound travels there.
Or maybe you take it out to
the field and you look and see
how sound travels there.
And maybe you ask
this question, what
is the loudest room
in the school anyway?
JULIE FARAGO: I love the vision.
I love the division
of data fluency
and helping teach our kids that.
It's fabulous.
And also creating these
cool scientific instruments.
And the question is, how
do you, as a developer,
enable this type of data
fluency-- this cross device
data gathering and
analysis and collaboration?
And you already know how
to use the Android Media
APIs because you've already
done that with the photos.
But let's look at the APIs
for data collaboration
and for collection.
So as it turns out
there are actually
more than 30 million
active apps for Edu users.
These students and
teachers use tools
like Google Docs and
Google Spreadsheets
to create content and
collaborate around it
all the time, which is
exactly what we want to do.
So our Spreadsheets
API offers the ability
to create spreadsheets,
add rows of data,
manipulate individual
cells of data,
and basically you
can use it as a place
to store all that awesome
audio data that your kids are
gathering.
And then those kids can
go into Google Drive,
they can collaboratively
create charts and understand
how sound travels
through and compares
across different locations.
And then you can
even do more things,
like use the Drive
APIs for Google Docs
or for Google Spreadsheets,
which are all very similar.
So we'd be really excited
if you also checked out
the developer site
for the Drive APIs.
RICK BOROVOY: So bringing
it all together here.
Our goal with Google
Play for Education
for all these
awesome Google APIs
is to make it really easy for
you to build some apps that
make some collaborative learning
activities easy for kids.
And then to make it easy
for schools to find those
apps and just start
using them right away.
JULIE FARAGO: Absolutely.
So we want it to be easy
for teachers, easy for you,
easy for students.
Easy, easy, easy.
So please go do it.
We cannot wait to see what
you're going to build.